- Ah, nature, hi, I'm Garrett.
- And I'm Niki!
- We're fascinated
by how other people live.
- So we're gonna try and
find some really interesting
living situations.
- And live there,
experiencing a totally
different lifestyle.
- To see which ones
bring us closer together,
- Or push us further apart.
- This week,
we're living in a tree house!
- It's over there.
- That one.
- Yeah.
(upbeat rock music)
- I'm Dave.
- And I'm Hollis.
We live just outside of Sandy, Oregon
on the way to Mount Hood.
- We have 20 acres here,
and this is our tree house,
which we started building in
2010 and finished in 2015.
- [Garrett] Look at it, there it is!
- [Niki] So you built this?
- [Dave] We did!
- [Hollis] We did!
- [Garrett] That's amazing!
- I think one of the
things about the tree house
is it gets us away from our
own house and our own lives.
It just really puts you
in a very peaceful state
to be up amongst the trees.
- [Garrett] Niki and I
are about to go to live in a tree house.
Niki's kind of planned of this tree house.
She seems really excited.
It's in the Pacific Northwest
where she's from.
- [Niki] It's gonna be cloudy,
rainy, a little bit cold,
I'm bringing all my sweaters.
- For the tree house we're gonna be
investigating two things.
One is it a good place
to live just on its own.
- And two is it a space that
brings us closer together
or will it push us further apart?
- The tree house is actually
suspended, so when you're
in the tree house if
it moves a little bit,
- It's supposed to do that.
- That's all good.
- It's like a little cabin
that you've elevated.
Like you've just sort of
made it harder for yourself.
- It's definitely an
alternative lifestyle.
This is not gonna be
like my apartment in LA.
- Come on in.
- Alright.
- Oh wow, Oh!
- Oh my gosh.
(orchestral music)
- [Dave] Whenever we had
an opportunity to use
products from the property, we did so
as you lay in the bed
the timbers up above you
are actually milled from
down trees on our property.
- The floor is made out
of ground paper bags.
- [Garrett & Niki] What?!
- And this is a tree?
- [Dave] That is a tree.
- [Hollis] That's a tree.
- Around the loft there's
two twin beds up there.
- Oh my gosh, look at that,
it looks so nice up here.
If I were a kid this is where
I would be all the time.
- I think the main challenge
we're gonna experience
is plumbing because practically speaking,
I don't know how that works.
- So this is the light
switch for the bathroom
but go ahead and go in, I
think I turned one already.
- Oh my gosh!
- The toilet is a composting
toilet so you don't
stand up to use it.
It's important that the
liquids don't get into the rear
sections, so that's why everybody sits.
- I'm kind of amazed
that you have a bathroom
in a tree to begin with.
- Yeah, (laughing) that
alone is pretty remarkable.
- Yeah (laughing)
- Actually, it's perfect size.
It's gonna be like the
tiny house situation again.
Where Niki and I are
basically forced to be staring
at each other the whole time,
especially if it's raining.
- I think that's it up here.
- I think that is.
- Can we show you
- Yes
- The outdoor shower?
- Yes, absolutely.
- Okay, so, come on in.
- Wow!
- That's more
than just a front, it's
like a sauna or steam room.
- We put some towels
out here for you guys.
So what you do here is you press it in.
Just slide the switch down
and you'll hear that come on.
- Whoa!
- And
- There's a heater!
- Oh my gosh, that's instant.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's amazing.
- It is, you know we'll
run out of hot water.
- Well, I call it a magical
tree house because you could
wake up in the morning
and look straight out
at the branches
- Into the trees.
- intro the trees.
- I envisioned, really
building it for ourselves
and for our family and I think
for me, the biggest surprise
has been how much I've enjoyed
sharing it with other people.
- This place seems like
a really ideal place
for me to live, like, I love the climate.
I love the Northwest,
being surrounded by trees,
and woods, and land is
so peaceful and quiet.
- I'm afraid the tree house is
something pretty hip and cool
but actually is very
inconvenient and not the best
situation for roommates.
- Phew, it's so cold.
So, we're in the tree house, this is it.
- It's very cute, it's very cozy.
- It's so dark.
- Like you just look
out all of the windows
and there's just nothingness.
- Really cool that there's
nothing underneath us right now.
- Yeah, that's crazy.
- We're actually like floating
between two trees and like
we can....I'm literally
rocking the house, it's really funny.
- Yeah, don't do that,
but it's very secure.
This is not like a
rinky-dink kids tree house.
- No this is not like a
project that was built
over a summer.
The bathroom is probably the
biggest source of anxiety right now.
- Yeah, it's very small.
- It's so small.
It's about the size of
an airplane bathroom.
- And that's it, I fit
in here and that's it.
- This is like a very long, far away sink
(Laughing)
- Cold huh?
- Yeah, it's really stupid.
- But there is a bathroom
in here, which I thought
we would have to go outside
to use the bathroom.
- Yeah, its so much
better than an outhouse.
- Alright that's like
- Bye!
- Extremely disrespectful.
- (Laughing) That's kinda
nice, okay so that's,
- So this is our privacy partition.
- So we can change.
- Wanna put these on?
- Yeah.
These are like space booties.
- I think that by the end of the this.
You'll love it and you'll
love Oregon because of it.
(upbeat music)
- That's the sound of the
rain, it's raining all night.
So tired last night so
I slept in but I think
we're gonna make breakfast?
I gotta put on a lot
of clothes to go outside right now.
Cause it's very cold and rainy.
- We're just gonna let
that heat up a little bit
get the, dry it off, warm up my hands.
Niki's still asleep so, you're like
my only entertainment
here is to talk to you.
I mean in theory this is nice right?
It's pleasant, we're
outdoors, we're grilling.
If I had to do this for
breakfast every morning,
I probably wouldn't eat breakfast ever.
But it's just like a lot
of kind of inconvenience.
Nope, see, like, it's just not hot yet.
My nose is starting to
run, it's just like not
(laughing)
It looks sad!
Because this won't get hot,
this is gonna take forever.
Is there such a thing as slow cooked bacon
cause that's what I'm making.
Oh, good morning.
- Good morning.
- I can't get this pan hot enough.
- Isn't this a burner?
- Uh, I think it's just
like a heater, I think it
just like keeps things warm.
- I think that might be a burner.
- This is a burner!
- Told you!
- Aw, shit, luckily it seems
like the rain is dying.
- And then we gotta get
stuff to grill for dinner.
- Ugh, you wanna grill
somethin' for dinner?
- Yeah, how else we gonna eat dinner?
- I don't know I guess we have to.
You think I don't like
this because I don't like
being outdoors, but it's the opposite.
I like being outdoors but this is not
where you should be outdoors.
- Yes it is!
It's beautiful!
- It's soaking wet and cold.
- Grumble, grumble, grumble (laughing)
- You showin' off?
(growling dogs)
- Did you put another
piece of bacon on there
in between the two?
- Yum, Mmmmm!
- You get this one.
This is kinda nice, us with
our dogs, sitting by the fire.
As long as we keep figuring
out other stuff to do.
- Stop being so concerned
about what we're gonna do.
Just live.
Cheers!
- There's Garrett on his
way to shower, right there.
It's been a minute since
we had coffee and breakfast
and I have to poop.
No one else is in here
right now, which I feel is
the proper time to do it.
I was a little confused
at how to use the toilet
but I think I figured it out (giggling).
- It's very romantic that
I have this (laughing)
fireplace here.
Turn on water
using black switch.
How do you, he made it
look so easy yesterday.
Ah, there we go.
Ooh!
And it's already pretty warm.
Kinda nice, I mean,
they said it's infinite hot
water so I can just kinda
take my time.
- I did it.
They didn't come back yet.
It was easier than I thought,
it's a composting toilet,
that's why it's complicated.
Also, there's a toilet in the shower so
worse comes to worse, I have
to go poop outside next time.
- All showered.
(uptempo music)
I'm going to do the pendulum swing.
- Okay
- You're gonna help me.
This is a two person affair
- Oh my, okay.
- It's literally just some toy
that Dave built in the woods.
It's so hard, okay ready.
- Oh I wanna see this.
- (laughing) That's really fun, oh god!
Jesus, (laughing) okay, so it's dangerous.
- Oh!
- Parcour
- Alright, ready, three, two, one
(yelling and laughing)
- No, don't push me!
- I don't know maybe.
(laughing)
See who it is
- Oh, hello
- Are you our tour guide Henry?
- This is stuff that
like we could never do
in like LA you know.
The idea that you could
own this much land, like,
that's incredible.
Stop!
Go!
Yeah, those are fish eatin' dog food.
Stop it!
So, this is gonna happen.
Go for it!
(playful music)
- Ach, it's gonna be cold!!
(loud splash)
(laughing)
- It's cold, holy shit!
It's cold, it's cold, but it was fun!
(laughing)
- Niki, we have to eat dinner?
- (giggling) Okay.
I'm so cozy (laughing)
Alright, hot dogs.
Man, it's chilly out here.
- I can't see anything.
- Hot dogs are already cooked
so you just gotta heat 'em up really.
Did you burn them, are you burning things?
- I can't see, I don't know.
Doesn't this kinda suck
that we have to be outside
in the freezing cold, just
to make food all the time?
- A little bit.
- But, it was fun
doing the zip line stuff.
- Today was a fun day.
- It was fun.
- Doing outdoor stuff.
- Well
- Cheers
(playful music)
- You know any ghost stories?
- No, I don't like
ghost stories.
So, today after our
activities we went into town
and I wasn't feeling super well after
and when we got back to
the tree house I ended up
throwing up a few times and poor Garrett
had to essentially like watch, and hear me
just barf into a bag.
- Niki's not feeling very well
Niki and I have lived together
in like one room before
but never with one person feeling sick.
Trying to make her feel
better, trying to make sure
she's drinking liquids.
Actually, today became
really fun eventually.
Niki kind of helped me
get out of my comfort zone
a little bit.
Once I accepted that
it's wet out and it's a
little colder out then it
became a lot easier to have fun.
And like, I still went,
like swimming today.
I started to actually see
liking to live in a tree house
isn't really about the tree house itself.
It's about all the other
things that come with it.
And I couldn't have understood
that until I came here
and started living it.
So far, I think my relationship
with Niki has improved
a little bit but we'll see
if she thinks that tomorrow
when hopefully she's feeling better
cause she really was
looking forward to this.
So hopefully that didn't drag
her experience down too much.
Cause she improved my experience.
(dripping rain)
How are you feeling Niki?
- Better
- That's good.
- Sorry for throwing up in front of you.
- I don't care.
We slept so late today.
- I know.
- We slept like 10 hours.
- It's so dark up there.
- It's so dark.
- But I like waking up in the trees.
Alright, we did it, we
lived in a tree house.
I had a lot of fun despite
throwing up several times
last night.
- When you sign-up to live in a tree house
the number one thing on your
list is not practicalities.
Is it fun for a couple of days?
Yes, it's a lot of fun.
- This living situation,
by default did bring us closer together
because we like shared
a tiny loft together.
He totally like released
his inner child yesterday
of like running around the
property, doing the zip line,
getting on the pendulum swing,
so it was fun to see him
like kind of drop all
sense of practicalities
and just kind of enjoy it.
- Good-bye tree house.
- Bye tree house.
- [Announcer] Next week on Home Buddies
- RV
- Recreational Vehicle
This is probably the most
different living style we've done.
- I'm just really worried about
a poop situation happening.
- Here I am at the Grand Caymans.
- There are too many obstacles.
- Yeah, it always is great for you.
- He wants to be in control.
- I'm trying
not to become defensive.
(Grunting)
- I think we're gonna be
at each other's throats.
(upbeat music)